the Republican candidate and today's
special congressional election in
Montana is charged with misdemeanor
assault billionaire businessman Greg
Jian Forte is accused of body slamming
reporter Ben Jacobs last night Jacobs
recorded audio of the incident you got
the last came here you did the same
thing
get the hell eyes at least three Montana
newspapers withdrew their endorsements
late last night after gene for Tay was
charged he and Democrat Rob Quist are
competing for the states only US House
seat after Ryan Zinke resigned to become
interior secretary Meg Oliver recently
traveled to Montana to cover the race
Meg good morning Nora good morning the
most recent polling in the Republican
stronghold Montana shows Greg Jian for
Tay with a double-digit lead Republican
groups have pumped millions in to defend
the House seat
The Guardian reporter was looking for GN
Forte's stance on House health care
legislation yesterday when he ended up
on the floor with the candidate on top
of him I wasn't expecting detailed
policy but then again I also wasn't
expecting to be bodyslam Montana's
Republican candidate for Congress Greg
gene forte was charged with misdemeanor
assault after he allegedly attacked a
reporter at his campaign headquarters
talk to you about that later yeah but
there's not gonna be time adjusters
figured Shane please
tired you guys the last house it came
here you did the same thing
get the hell I get the hell out the last
I do that same to you in The Guardian
yes if you just broke my glasses
you last guys do the same damn thing you
just body slimy it broke my glasses get
the hell out of here political reporter
Ben Jacobs took this photo from inside
an ambulance Wednesday it's on top of me
for a second my glasses are broken its
strangest the strangest moment didn't my
entire life reporting Fox News
correspondent Alicia hakuna witnessed
the attack and backed up Jacobs account
writing Gian Forte grabbed Jacobs by the
net with both hands and slammed him into
the ground
Gian Forte then began punching the
reporter jan 40s the account from both
reporters contradicts a statement
released by Gian Forte's office which
said Jacobs aggressively shoved a
reporter in Greg's face and said Jacobs
grabbed Gregg's wrist and spun away from
Greg pushing them both to the ground
afterwards Gian for Tate was spotted in
this car Gian 14 challenger Democrat Rob
Quist remained upbeat I'll always be a
montana side CBS News was in Bozeman to
interview Gian Forte last month people
have lost faith in Washington we've got
federal agencies that are way outside
their sandbox we need to rein them back
in this incident might not move the
needle close to 260,000 Montanans have
already voted by absentee ballot an
estimated 700,000 are eligible to vote
the misdemeanor assault charge will
require Jan 14 in court before the
second week of June Charlie thanks Meg